um well actually before we get into the
cabinet appointments what is your view
on the potential delay to that financial
statement on October the 31st I mean
clearly British sunak has only just got
his feet under the desk but he
presumably knows what's been going on
should they go ahead on Monday I'm both
surprised and alarmed to hear James
cleverley saying that because we've been
waiting on these forecasts in particular
for the office of budget responsibility
for a very long time we don't yet fully
know the scale of the damage that the
conservatives have called to our economy
you know when they crashed it when we've
seen all this chaos and we do need to
see those forecasts and we'll only see
those forecasts when they press ahead
with this statement so I think we do
need to see it as soon as possible but
this is just this never-ending chaos
that we see at the heart of government
big decisions not being taken and it
creates massive problems for our country
because it becomes all about the
conservative party when we Face such big
challenges as a country that are just
not being addressed would you not
consider that at least on the basis of
the speech that Rishi sunak gave before
entering number 10 yesterday that it
does feel like we are in a slightly
different area of conservative
governments that perhaps some of the
adults has finally got their hands back
on the steering wheel I'm afraid I don't
feel it that way and you know Richard
Cena stood in front of Downing Street
and said that he would was going to
bring Integrity back to his government
and then he appoints to Ella Brad and
then back as Home Secretary someone who
just last week broke the ministerial
called an issue of National Security and
you know clearly he struck some kind of
grubby deal with her to bring her back
with the promise of her support but
again this is all about the conservative
party this has been going on for months
now and that's why I think it's only
right that the British people get the
chance to have their say this should be
about them not unifying the conservative
party I mean swella Bravo and James
cleverly and indeed Rishi soon I would
all presumably say look she made a
mistake and she apologized for it a
mistake similar to the one you know that
David Lammy made well 16 times when he
failed to register 16 interests on on
the registered members interest
including payments for tickets to boxing
matches I mean you know he's still in
his post so I shouldn't swell around
government and arguably a more important
position than the shadow of foreign
secretary why shouldn't she I think it
is hard to compare the two examples that
you've just given there but we don't
actually know the full extent of what's
gone on here you know we haven't had
questions answered around was this the
only occasion which Zoella Brotherman
conducted this kind of government
business on a personal email account
sharing sensitive documents she refuses
to answer these questions we haven't had
straight answers on it
um and so I think you know unless we get
to that point we don't know if this is
the only occasion which she's done it
um but we know that you know she's the
Home Secretary responsible for issues of
National Security responsible for
keeping us all safe for our police and
she behaves like this and for Rishi
saying that to say this is integrity in
government well I think that really is
hard to stand up the the one thing I
haven't heard you mention yet this
morning in fact they couldn't stop labor
figures from from shouting about
opposition figures I should say from
shouting about it yesterday is the
prospect of an early general election I
mean is that still Labor's ambition to
somehow Force the government into a
position where they have to take this to
the electorate you know we've had three
conservative Prime Ministers now in
three months and it really is getting
ridiculous I do think the British people
deserve to have their say in a general
election they've not had a look in
conservative MPS they've had two
opportunities now to choose the Prime
Minister the British people they haven't
and wherever I go people say to me they
want the chance to have theirs there
isn't anything constitutely improper
about it so I wonder just how you might
get there because I can't see everybody
it's hard for us absolutely we don't
have majority in Parliament but it won't
stop us saying that it's a necessity
because this isn't going to win this is
this is not going to stop this chaos and
we do face real impressing challenges as
a country whether it's on the cost of
living around creating new great jobs
around skills around childcare there's
so much that we need to change in our
country and we're only going to see that
change with the labor government what
should we expect to see from secure
starmer then at the dispatch box at pmqs
today I mean will he go after Mr sunax
admittedly pretty substantial personal
wealth at the time of our cost of living
crisis I'm most interested in Richie
sunax record and of course he was
Chancellor for a prolonged period of
time and I think you look at his record
as Chancellor someone who said where it
comes to supporting our children coming
out with the pandemic that he maxed out
on the support that was available to
them he presided over industrial scale
fraud and waste he refused to try and
make efforts to get that money back
terrible value for the taxpayer dodgy
contracts going out to friends and
donors of the conservative party and now
he has the brass neck to come and
lecture us all on tough choices there's
one really easy area of course where he
could raise some extra money and that's
by fall following our call to end the
tax breaks the private schools enjoy I
think that's a really easy and
straightforward choice if he tells us
there are tough choices to make get on
and do that 1.7 billion pounds we could
push into State education just just on
your brief then for a second and as we
get the edge ever close I mean you'll
have noticed coming into the building
today things are definitely getting a
little bit colder covert will of course
be a concern in the latter part of of
this year how are our schools prepared
for the next winter wave of covert which
we will have to have year after year for
some time yet I think because of so much
of the delay and inability to make
decisions at the heart of government we
haven't actually been planning in the
way that we ought to for some of this so
we haven't properly considered the rule
for ventilation in our schools that
applies in the winter as much as it does
in the summer and the government haven't
published the research that we need to
see in making those kinds of decisions
but our schools and our staff and
teachers and school school support staff
are under enormous pressure right now I
mean not just the pressures of covid but
you know when I visit schools I hear
about children arriving at school
um not having been fed you know the
pressures on family budgets I think you
know that's why I've said that we should
deliver breakfast clubs for every
Primary School child in England and we
pay for that by ending the non-dom tax
status again another area where the
government could and should act to make
a difference I mean so when Richie said
that yesterday promised outside number
10 that we would be seeing improvements
to education improvements to our schools
I mean in your mind can that be achieved
without real-time spending increases I
think our schools are facing a really
difficult uh you know couple of years
ahead I mean I would say the only reason
that we're actually even thinking about
these kinds of spending cuts to our
Public Services it's because the
conservatives crushed the economy we
haven't been having this conversation
about yeah they made it worse they did
make it worse admittedly but it's not
entirely up there well they haven't
invested in education properly for the
last 12 years absolutely we haven't seen
the kinds of investment that is needed
because we know that if we invest in our
children young people we invest in the
future of our country but I think where
it comes to adult learning as well we
Face a real Challenge on climate change
but actually a great opportunity to
provide well-paid highly skilled jobs
across our country but we have to have a
skilled Workforce that can retrain and
upskill throughout their lives too and
that's what we're talking about today
with the launch of David blunkett's
report for the labor party it will be a
very very interesting addition to pmqs
anyway I'm sure Bridget Phillips lovely
to see it